more from the war on american history
camilla harris spoke at the national
congress of american indians it's their
78th annual convention this is on
tuesday
and she just had once she began of
course
as they must with one long apology for
american history and here's what that
sounded like
since
1934
every october the united states has
recognized the voyage of the european
explorers who first landed on the shores
of the americas
but that is not the whole story
that has never
been the whole story
those explorers
ushered in a wave of devastation for
tribal nations
perpetrating violence
stealing land
and spreading disease
we must not shy away
from this shameful past
and we must shed light on it
and do everything we can to address the
impact of the past
on native communities today
yeah those dastardly european explorers
those bastards
bringing civilization to this part of
the globe
how dare they
yeah we ought to apologize for that we
really should
uh just like we should and and and
frankly as as a white man um i would
like to apologize for
all of the deeds of uh white western men
because white western men have done a
lot of terrible things including
bringing civilization to this part of
the globe you know
i guess they they never should have come
i guess that's the uh the stance people
like camila harris they never should
have come
civilization should have should have
stopped
should have stopped dead on the other
side of the atlantic and and never
traveled across
yeah and then it'd be a utopia here
the indigenous tribes were 3 000 years
behind uh
you know but behind behind
civilization
and it should have been able to it
should it should have stayed that way
where you've got one side of the globe
advancing and everything and then this
entire part of the globe is just left
to be in the stone age
that's that's what should have happened
right
so we should apologize for that i think
also as a white western man i should
apologize for
you know modern medicine
apologize for science for space travel
for electricity for air conditioning for
democracy for automobiles for airplanes
for human rights for computers for
plumbing for the printing press
all of those terrible deeds of white
western men i apologize for all that but
um
i want to make one other point about
this
because
you know one of the other problems here
with all of this constant apologizing
and the way that this clash of
civilizations
european versus uh
the the you know indigenous tribes
one of the other problems with the way
that it's presented
is that yeah we've talked about how the
europeans are are turned into these
cartoonish
villains in this black and white
scenario
but also we make the indian tribes
into these sort of lame
victims
when when really they weren't
uh yeah in in terms of technological
advancement and uh and you know
philosophy and government and
in every other way they were far behind
most of the rest of the world
but even so
i mean take take for example the
comanche tribe just just said just as
one example one of the tribes of the
great great plains um
and there was a i've told you before
about a great book written by the author
s c gwen who has
several really good history books
including one about stonewall jackson
called rebel yell that you should read
but he wrote a book called the empire of
the summer moon
and this is about the comanche tribe not
focusing primarily on the indian wards
which were not in columbus this time of
course this was in the in the
mid to late 19th century but the
comanche tribe
very impressive
and a very impressive and interesting
history
you know they were they were masters of
the horse the spanish broad i mean the
horses
horses are not indigenous to this part
of the globe
so the indian tribes didn't have them
until the spanish brought them over in
the the 16th century
and that just revolutionized
so many things
among the indian tribes and the
comanches many of the tribes in the
great plains became masters of the horse
even more so than than than the
europeans and comanches especially
what they were able to do with a horse
riding bareback on the horses like
something out of you know it's something
out of an action film what they were
able to do
um
and they had this entire empire
but they were also a brutal
warfaring
violent people
and they struck terror in the the hearts
and minds of other tribes around them
and also the the white settlers
whose settlements they would would often
raid and
murder everyone take a you know kidnap
and enslave people
um
that's that's that's part of the story
but when you know
with the way that the indians are
presented
people like camille harris they don't
want to talk about that stuff they don't
want to tell you about the raids that
they would do the violence and
everything they want to leave all of
that out
but then in the process by by sanitizing
this history and by sanitizing these
people and their culture you end with
something that's just kind of
lame and uninteresting
you turn all the indian tribes into a
bunch of just these sort of like loser
victims
who were sitting around utterly helpless
until the year the big bad europeans
came in
and wiped them all out all at once
when in fact this was a violent clash of
civilizations that went on for centuries
and many of these indian tribes
especially the comanches and others were
more than able to hold their own for
quite a long time
because they knew how to wage war
because they'd been doing it for
centuries before the europeans came
so it is a it's a fascinating period of
history
with fascinating figures on both sides
of it
and uh and you just lose all that when
you try to sanitize it
july 4th for many other americans is not
a time for something so frivolous as
happiness it is rather a time for anger
and sorrow
these are the americans who profess to
hate this country though they choose to
still live here gorging themselves
on the bounty of western civilization
while bitterly complaining about the
people who provided that bounty to them
most of these ungrateful whiny losers
can't even really explain why they hate
this country so much as this recent
video from campus reform uh demonstrates
are you proud to be an american
no
i feel embarrassed to be an american
every day um
not really in this climate no like i'm a
black person so obviously i experience a
lot of
uh
you know there's like oppression that
comes with that um
[Music]
not most of the time i think sometimes
it's just a little embarrassing you know
be proud of what and what is there to be
proud about if you're black and being
like you know because it's just like
it's a still a lot of stuff that goes on
for black people
i think that's a complicated question
for me i think i
i
i think most of the time no at least
over like the past four years um it's
been tricky to
you know love to be an american
well like america sucks you know because
like it oppresses black people or
whatever
how does it oppress
them what is the exact nature of this
oppression that's never explained the
people who hate america are like sullen
teenagers who go around complaining that
their lives are so difficult and
miserable even as they enjoy the easiest
and most painless existence that the
world can possibly offer to a human
being
in fact those same sullen teenagers
crying that they're being oppressed by
their parents because they aren't
allowed to stay out until 1am on a
school night or whatever it is often
grow up and turn into the sorts of
adults who cry that they're being
oppressed by society or systemic racism
or the patriarchy for reasons that are
even more superfluous
july 4th has now become an occasion for
such people to air their grievances and
while this is annoying and pathetic it's
also illuminating because in airing
their grievances you're able to see just
how stupid are those grievances and how
hypocritical and also stupid
are the ones airing them
so here's one representative example
that is worth i think some special
attention
this comes from a twitter account called
lakotaman
um his bio tells us that he has a ba in
sociology
you perhaps can already guess where this
is headed simply based on the fact that
this is the kind of guy who brags about
having a bachelor's degree in sociology
on july 4th lakotaman ba tweeted this he
says hey america fu for desecrating our
sacred mountain hashtag happy fourth and
it's accompanied by a picture of
presumably himself and two other people
pointing their middle fingers at mount
rushmore
now many questions potentially arise
questions like
what sort of person drives all the way
out to mount rushmore just to flip off a
bunch of rocks
i guess it kind of reminds me of the
time when i drove four hours to the
beach in order to scream at a mound of
sand
it's really annoying when sand gets in
your shoes and i just thought it was
time that someone finally sent the
message
but in any case more to the point let's
consider the specific complaint that
lakota man b.a has here he says that
america has desecrated his sacred
mountain the black hills
by carving the mount rushmore sculpture
into it
he also says in subsequent tweets that
this was land theft and colonization etc
now this claim of land theft made by
modern native americans is almost always
species and hypocritical but when it's
made by someone descended from the
lakota tribe about the black hills
the irony is even more pronounced
lakota man ba says that his people owned
the black hills it was sacred to them
the white man ruthlessly stole and
desecrated the land that belonged to
them
but does that mean that the lakota were
the first to inhabit this region of the
country no far from it before the lakota
the black holes were occupied by the
arapaho in fact the chain of possession
during recorded history goes back to the
16th century and during that time the
land was claimed by the arapaho kiowa
crow cheyenne and arikara tribes before
we got to the um
to the lakota
and that's only recorded history
archaeologists tell us that the very
very first occupants of this region were
called the clovis people about 13 000
years ago
well archaeologists did tell us that now
we're told that the clovis people came
somewhat more recently and they're
predated by another group of people who
we know very little about
the point is that the black hills
his sacred mountains
are not his at all
his people were not the first to occupy
it not the second not the third not the
fourth not the fifth not the sixth
indeed the lakota came in the 19th
century moved everyone else out took
over and immediately declared the
mountains sacred to them
like they just got there killed a bunch
of people and said these mountains are
sacred
keep something in mind here when we say
that one tribe moved other tribes out of
the region
we don't mean that they asked them to
politely to leave okay they didn't show
up
with a with a with a note and say well
would you hey guys would you mind
skedaddling here
would you would you mind moving over and
giving up some space would you mind
that's not how it worked
in indian culture war over land was very
common and it was very
very brutal
slaughter decapitation dismemberment
rape enslavement
scalping
were all common features of these
conflicts
speaking of scalping um the earliest the
earliest evidence that we have of this
practice to my knowledge
dates to the 14th century in south
dakota
a mass grave from that period has been
uncovered and we don't know exactly what
happened
but whatever happened it's been dubbed
the crow creek massacre because the
human remains show that hundreds of
people were cut to pieces scalped
tortured mutilated
and this is before any white man had set
foot on that part of the globe way
before
which means that um that that one native
american tribe
did that to another
and there's nothing especially
surprising about that
that's how they treated each other and
that's what they did when they wanted to
take the land occupied by some other
group
now bringing this back to the black
hills
one indian tribe conquered and massacred
another tribe for access to that land
and then that tribe was conquered and
massacred by another and so on and so
until finally
not but a century or so before the white
man showed up the lakota came and did
the same stealing the land from the
thieves that had most recently stealing
stolen it before them
then a short time later in the grand
scheme of things the us government rolls
in and a series of battles are fought
over those mountains called the black
hills wharf
and the us won the battle
that is
the u.s conquered the people who had
most recently conquered the land
we're left then with the with the
original question
who owns that land
if you say that conquest is illegitimate
and it's always wrong to conquer land
and overthrow the people occupying it
then you can't say that the the lakota
own it because they did the same
and you can't say that the cheyenne own
it or the acaira or the the kiowa
so who owns it
who's the victim of this theft
the clovis people with their stone tools
13 000 years ago
maybe we should find some of them and
apologize
but they weren't there first either
they somehow came to supplant some other
stone age people before them and i can
pretty much guarantee you that that
supplanting was not peaceful
very few things were at that point in
our history
this is the absurd rabbit hole that you
fall down whenever you try to claim that
the u.s stole the land it currently
occupies
in order for a thing to be stolen it
must first be owned
but if you say that the most recent
indian tribe who lived on it owned it
then you're legitimizing conquest and if
you legitimize conquest then there's no
reason why the united states conquest
should not be considered legitimate
as i've argued many times
conquest was the way of the world all
over the world everywhere among all
people for thousands of years if you
wanted it
you took it
if you wanted to keep it you defended it
if you couldn't defend it you lost it
if you couldn't take it you didn't get
it
as simple as that
america didn't invent this concept we
didn't even practice the most brutal
form of it not even close
today we're simply blamed
because we were better at it
americans played the exact same game the
indians played they observed the exact
same rule of conquest a brutal rule but
a universal one and they were just
better at it
they won
and now we're supposed to be ashamed of
that victory and weep over it and
apologize
centuries later but apologize to who
the conquerors who were conquered
the thieves who had their stolen goods
stolen
that's absurd
i for one apologize for nothing and i'm
ashamed of nothing
and i'm happy that america is here and
i'm happy that it won that conflict and
that war
i'm happy that this civilization is here
i would rather live in this civilization
and i think everyone would including the
lakota man b.a
but anyone who is ashamed of america is
free to leave
you know one of the difficulties of
living in a country where half of the
people have gone entirely insane is that
it's hard to tell what's real and what
isn't
it's easy to get suckered by trolls and
satirists because the troll and the
satirist
can't present a version of reality any
more absurd than the one we actually
live in so it's kind of
it's anyone's guess what's real and what
is it and that's why um that's why i
present the following story with some
trepidation
relatively sure that it's real but i can
never be completely sure
so on twitter over the weekend
conservative commentator kathleen
mckinley posted a screenshot of um
of a letter
that was apparently distributed by two
white families in a wealthy suburb of
dallas
by some kind of racial activist group
they went around giving this letter to
white families in this
wealthy liberal neighborhood
the post-millennial has some of the
details here it says dallas justice now
a racial equity advocacy group has been
actively campaigning to convince wealthy
white liberal families to not send their
white children to ivy league schools or
other top 50 collegiate institutions so
that admission spots are available for
people of color to quote correct
historical wrongs an organization
reporting to be a racial justice group
has been sending letters informing white
affluent democrats about the college
pledge around dallas's richest
neighborhood richest neighborhood such
as storied highland park
and then uh and then here's some of the
what the letter actually says and this
again was in a screenshot uh this was
left i don't know put under people's
doors or in their mailbox i'm not sure
and the letter says
quote we are writing to you because we
understand you are white and live within
the highland park independent school
district and thus benefit from enormous
privilege taken at the expense of
communities of color you live in the
whitest and wealthiest neighborhood in
dallas whether you know it or not you
earned or inherited your money through
oppressing people of color however it's
also our understanding that you're a
democrat and supporter of the black
lives matter movement which makes you
one of our white allies and puts you in
a position to help correct these cruel
injustices we need you to step up and
back up your words with action and truly
sacrifice to make our segregated city
more just
the letter then asks rather demands i
should say that they pledge not to send
their children to an ivy league school
or any school listed in the top 50 by
u.s news and world report
generously
the group does admit
that this is a quote tough commitment to
make
but they point out that if you're going
to have a black lives matter sign in
your yard
you ought to be ready to make these
kinds of sacrifices
the post-millennial has a little bit
more they say on the group's website
white parents can take the pledge online
the pledge form asks users um reading it
says will you will you take the college
pledge
there are two options available for
users to choose here are the two options
you can take the college pledge that's
the question two options
i am a racist hypocrite or i agree
it says talk is not enough commit
yourself towards taking action and
making sacrifices to correct centuries
of injustice the pledge's description is
trucks open up spaces for black and
latinx communities by refusing to send
your kids to ivy league and u.s news
world report top 50 schools and
encourage friends neighbors and family
members to do the same
imagine if those hundreds of thousands
of spots at these institutions were
occupied only by marginalized
communities
imagine the opportunities we can achieve
true
equity within our lifetimes but only if
white folks
are willing to sacrifice their
privileges
uh and then a little bit of the pledge
is as a white person with privilege both
from my whiteness and maine and my
neighborhood i recognize the need to
make sacrifices for the purpose of
correcting hundreds of years of murder
slavery discrimination and lack of
educational and economic opportunities
perpetrated upon people of color
okay if this is a i should say if this
is a a troll job
it's a pretty committed one because i
looked at the website myself and it
certainly appears legitimate the group
also has a very active twitter presence
which includes
this video which i'll play for you from
a member a member of the group named
jameel recorded this video here she is
explaining
why they're asking white families to
clear the deck and keep their kids out
of our nation's top schools here it is
we are fighting for change
we are fighting for equality
we are
wanting to bridge gaps and we just want
to catch up
i am a parent myself and i would love to
be able to send my children to college i
feel that not only sending my children
to college would not just be a good
thing for them a good thing for us
but also in the future to come their
kids will say hey mom dad went to
college i'm going to do that too
therefore i will be creating
generational wealth in my family and i
believe it's a trickle-down effect
the kids in the community the kids that
come over and play the kids that will
come and come over and play with my kids
kids
they'll all be affected by that because
they'll see it they'll see it
they'll feel it
i believe that it is my
burden it is our burden to use our
voices our platforms to spread awareness
to offer options and
choices on how others can support the
cause on how others
can make the dream become a reality
so again we're just a non-profit
advocacy group
seeking change
seeking quality
seeking justice
that's it
that's all they're seeking change
equality justice
and for you to totally debase and submit
yourselves to them and their authority
and their power that's it
that's all
is that too much to ask really
president trump announced that he was
forming the 1776 commission to counter
the anti-american anti-truth
indoctrination
in our schools and other institutions
the focus was especially on debunking
the noxious lies told to the public and
in particular our children
by proponents of critical race theory
and the 1619 project and similar
things ultimately the the commission's
goal was to offer a corrective to
leftist historical revisionism and to
promote as trump calls it
patriotic education now to my mind
uh this is not only a noble endeavor but
perhaps one of the most important things
trump has done with his presidency
any attempt to
reverse the cultural tide must begin by
addressing the fundamental sickness in
our education system entire generations
are being trained from the youngest ages
to hate their country and if they're
white
despise their ancestors and themselves
so this is not simply a matter of kids
being brainwashed into a lack of
patriotism
at a much deeper level they're being
conditioned to believe and build their
worldview around
what is not true
so i would much rather we call the
corrective truthful education rather
than patriotic education i'm not going
to quibble much over over those sorts of
details but that's really what we're
talking about here
yesterday the 1776 commission released
released its report uh reaffirming the
basic truths of america's founding and
offering its critiques of the radical
leftist version of history the final
product is about 45 pages long it's well
worth the read and if you take the time
to read it
you will already be one step ahead of
most of the
reports critics who do not appear to
have even skimmed the document before
issuing their many denunciations
for example cnn's headline declares
trump administration issues racist
school curriculum report on mlk day
by the way that's a that's not an op-ed
that's their news article calling it
racist
the washington post quotes outraged
historians who are incensed by the
report's quote outright lies
the new york times also claims that
quote historians are quote deriding it
for its false narratives
now a brief sampling of the post article
gives you an idea as to the general
flavor of the criticisms it says um
quoting now i don't know where to begin
said public historian alexis koh
this report lacked citations or any
indication books were consulted which
explains why it's riddled in errors
distortions and outright lies
cali nicole gross a history professor at
rutgers and emory universities and the
co-author of a black women's history of
the united states said it was dusty and
dated and the usual dodge on the long
lasting harmful impacts of settler
colonialism enslavement jim crow the
oppression of women the plight of queer
people as the true threat to democracy
this report makes it seem as if
slave-holding founding fathers were
abolitionists that americans were the
early beacons of the global abolitionist
movement the the demise of slavery in
the united states was inevitable boston
university historian ibram x kendi
tweeted it's very hard to find anything
in here that stands as a historical
claim or as the work of a historian
almost everything in it is wrong just as
a matter of fact said eric rochway
um
i may sound a little incoherent when
trying to speak of this because the
report itself is not coherent it's like
historical whack-a-mole
okay you'll notice here as as you'll
notice in nearly all the denunciations
of the 1776 report that little attempt
is made to engage
with the specific
and most essential historical claims
that it makes
we're simply assured that the report is
completely false and misguided and silly
and racist
but nobody issuing these assurances will
bother to explain why that cnn article
that called it racist at no point in the
article did it defend or justify or
explain that characterization
it just said well it's racist
you know
of course it is
in fact the critics say you know the
report isn't just wrong but incoherent
and this causes me to suspect that
perhaps these professional historians
are having trouble with the document
because they're illiterate which would
explain quite a lot about how history is
taught these days
and explain why they by their own
omission cannot seem to understand a
report that lays out its case very
clearly and cogently you can agree or
disagree with what the report says but
any literate person should at least be
able to comprehend what is being said
these historians can't even do that they
say they they just don't understand it
they're completely confused
mostly it seems that the scholarly
community takes great um umbrage with
the reports section on slavery that
that's that's the part that's gotten the
most attention
which they say dismisses or as
huffington post uh a huffington post
headline claims justifies the practice
of slavery that's what they're saying
they're saying that the report justifies
slavery
defends it
so let's read what it actually says on
the subject hopefully you'll find this
at least coherent i mean you tell me if
you can at a minimum understand what's
being said okay
this quote now from the 1776 uh
commission report
the most common charge leveled against
the founders and hence against our
country itself is that they were
hypocrites who didn't believe in their
stated principles and therefore the
country they built on rests on they
built rests on a lie
this charge is untrue and has done
enormous damage especially in recent
years with a devastating effect on our
civic unity and social fabric many
americans labor under the illusion that
slavery was somehow uniquely american
evil it is essential to insist at the
outset that the institution be seen in a
much broader perspective it's very hard
for people brought up in the comforts of
modern america in a time in which the
media in which the idea that all human
beings have invaluable in inviolable
rights and inherent dignity is almost
taken for granted to imagine the
cruelties and enormities that were
endemic in earlier times
but the unfortunate fact is that the
institution of slavery has been more the
rule than the exception throughout
history it was the western world's
repudiation of slavery only just
beginning to build at the time of the
american revolution which marked a
dramatic sea change in moral
sensibilities
the american founders were living on the
cusp of this change in a manner that
straddled two worlds
okay did you understand that
it seems coherent isn't it
i had no trouble understanding the point
it goes on to discuss the attitudes that
the founders had towards slavery some
were against it some were for it
some wrestled with the issue throughout
their lives uh ultimately of course
slavery was abolished in this country
and it only took america 90 years to do
it america was only a country for 90
years
uh give or take before slavery was
abolished compare that to the track
record of other nations some of which
have been around for millennia
and still to this day have not
completely abolished it right now
and when you do that you see that our
country is not guiltless but its guilt
is no greater than most any other nation
on earth and in many cases it's quite a
bit lesser
it may be hard for media people and
scholars to understand the simple but
crucial point being made here
that's either because they don't want to
understand or they're too stupid to
understand or both
the goal of critical race theory and of
the modern left generally is to saddle
white americans with a special and
lasting guilt
stemming from these historical
injustices and to paint america itself
as uniquely evil and almost singular
singularly responsible for atrocities
like slavery
this is wrong
and it matters that it's wrong
we cannot assess our own history or the
people who comprise it
if we do not have an accurate and a
complete understanding of the context in
which these people lived and acted
so we can quite easily and
self-assuredly sit here right now from
our comfortable position and condemn men
like george washington thomas jefferson
for not being racially enlightened
enough but but you know to thoughtful
people
it should make a difference
that washington and jefferson lived at a
time when almost nobody on the entire
planet was racially enlightened by our
standard stay
slavery was indeed a foregone conclusion
a normal part of life for nearly
everyone everywhere through all of human
history until the last couple of
centuries
we could have an interesting discussion
about why this was the case
how
was this the case how is it that the
whole world could have been so blind
to a moral truth that we all now see so
clearly and when i say we all i mean we
in the west because in other parts of
the world they still don't see it
but we cannot have that discussion if we
insist on absolving everyone everywhere
of guilt except for white men in north
america
the discussion becomes absurd
at that point and pointless
and whatever conclusions you draw will
be false and harmful
there'll be the conclusions of the 1619
project and critical race theory
which the 1776 report rightly condemns
now the report ends with this passage
which i like
it says to be an american means
something noble and good it means
treasuring freedom and embracing the
vitality of self-government
we are shaped by the beauty bounty and
wildness of our continent we are united
by the glory of our history we are
distinguished by the american virtues of
openness honesty optimism determination
generosity confidence kindness hard work
courage and hope
our principles did not create these
virtues but they laid the groundwork for
them to grow and spread and forge
america into the most just and glorious
country in all of human history
admittedly okay
some of that is a matter of opinion i'm
not sure there is any objective factual
measure for the gloriousness of a
country
but it's good for a person to feel this
way about his country
and there is good reason to feel this
way about our country
it's how many other people in many other
countries feel about their countries
all in all of those countries
have their own troubled histories their
own sins their own guilt
many cases much worse than our own
yet nobody would would would mock or
scold them
the people in those countries for their
patriotism
it's only us
we are the only ones the only ones who
are supposed to be ashamed of our
country and its history and as heroes we
are the only ones who are not supposed
to be too enthusiastic in our patriotism
you know we're supposed to issue a
thousand apologies as a preamble for
every good thing we say about our
country
at least
that's what they tell us at least that's
the rules they want to impose
and we should not listen
we should reject that